this
a big moment for a party at a Crossroads
I therefore declare Hunter Yusuf Julie
elected Hamza youssefs become Scottish
national party leader after a divisive
campaign the 37 year old said his
success as the Muslim son of immigrants
from Pakistan and Kenya shows there need
be no barriers in politics and he
promised to represent all of Scotland's
five and a half million people
yes my immediate priority will be to
continue to protect every Scot as far as
we possibly can from the harm inflicted
by the cost of living crisis to recover
and reform our NHS and other vital
Public Services of course these party's
main purpose is to deliver something
half the nation isn't convinced about
independence from the United Kingdom and
my solemn promise and commitment to you
is I will kick-start our Grassroots our
Civic LED movement and ensure our drive
for Independence is in fifth gear the
people of Scotland need Independence now
more than ever before and we will be the
generation that delivers Independence
for Scotland
but there are divisions within the SNP
that became clear well before outgoing
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon said
goodbye in the Scottish Parliament last
week I draw it to a close
Hunter Youssef says he feels like the
world's luckiest man leading a party he
joined 20 years ago but he clearly
realizes there are huge challenges ahead
in uniting the party and the country
behind him yusuf's closest Challenger
Kate Forbes possibly more popular Among
The Wider population did not support
Nicholas sturgeon's gender recognition
Bill making it easier for transgender
people to self-identify he now says as
first Minister he'll challenge the
Westminster government's block on that
legislation in the longer term he says
the SNP must take the time to convince
more people Independence is the Right
Way Forward I think it's a pragmatic
approach we need to to realize all of us
within the Scottish national party that
we've been bouncing around 50 for years
now and we need to break that impasse so
it's a new era for the SMP with huge
questions remaining over the future of
this small nation Nadine barber Al
Jazeera Edinburgh